the me people would
my task information everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my non-spoilery
review of Punisher season 2 I'll explain
what's going on what the producers have
said about possible season 3 obviously
all the actors have been talking about
it but if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
will do a new round of that IMAX
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Punisher moment on the video also ranked
this season against my favorite Marvel
Netflix seasons of the other shows at
the end of the video - they went the
Logan route which I feel like was a
smart move you pair the battle-worn
weari character like the punisher
grizzled old hero takes in a young girl
who they vow to protect at all costs she
softens him up inspires him and he
toughen her up at the same time but
because the Frank and Amy characters
aren't quite as sympathetic as the Logan
in Laura characters their relationship
just never quite hits the same highs
that you get from the Logan movie I mean
no big surprise the Logan movie is a
masterpiece of course it's gonna be
better than pretty much everything else
the Amy character was sort of a
replacement for the micro relationship
from season one you know I don't think
it's a spoiler to say that he does not
appear during season two which was a bit
of a surprise for me
they never really address it but he was
meant to be the comedic relief so you
pair those two characters up Amy was
kind of the comedic relief in the way
that Laura was the comedic relief in the
Logan relationship like he just tried to
react to all the crazy stuff that she
would do there been a lot of people that
have called it a sophomore slump I did
feel like the series was an improvement
on season one but it does suffer from a
bit of the Netflix bloat where you have
say like 8 to 10 episodes worth a story
that you stretch out into thirteen
episodes worth of content so they start
off real strong you get to see a more
balanced version of Frank Castle in the
introduction trying to enjoy life in for
a little while you think that he might
find some peace maybe find a new family
but then the real fun of those first
couple of episodes is the tension you
feel just waiting to find out what WTF
moment is gonna set it all off and draw
him back to darkness like what's gonna
pull him back into the game Ben Barnes
did a fantastic job as jigsaw he is the
main villain of the season if that
wasn't clear they have the john pilgrim
villain character but I'll talk about
him in a second the way they wrote the
jigsaw character during season two works
well because of all the work they did in
season one and his emotional connection
with the Punisher so he's haunted by
dreams of the Punisher from what
happened at the end of season one the
way they explained the jigsaw comic book
name is a bit of a left turn though they
use more of a mental thing so his mind
is a jigsaw of memories that he's trying
to piece back together so he doesn't
totally understand what happened between
him and Frank when the season picks up
he's confused about why he keeps
hallucinating the Punisher so a big part
of his season to arc is in piecing those
memories together and then answering the
question as to whether or not he's
capable of starting over and finding any
kind of redemption or if he'll just turn
evil again once he remembers what he did
during season one to his credit the show
does a really good job of answering all
those questions definitively by the
finale there's a very definite bookend
for his character there's no cliffhanger
or anything like that I know I'll get
into that when I talk about potential
season 3 stuff but if you've been a big
fan of the Karen page Punisher
relationship ever since the daredevil
season 2 they lean into that pretty
heavily
during this season they give you like a
couple brief moments to make you wonder
what's gonna happen between her and
daredevil and given the events of
daredevil season 3 it makes some of
their interactions all the more
interesting like some of the ways that
Karen acts around Punisher it does kind
of make you question the timeline like
hey wait a minute where's she and Matt
making like they were gonna get back
together at the end of daredevil season
3 but technically that didn't officially
happen at the end of daredevil season 3
they were gonna reform that new law firm
but I don't think they ever officially
answered the question of whether or not
they were going to be a couple again
you're going to move back into Matt
Murdock I just figured he has a
healthier life worth balance and actual
friends
- Nelson Murtagh and Paige Paige Murdoch
and Mills they just kind of implied like
they were in a better place and they
might get back together at some point
but they didn't definitively say oh yes
they're definitely a couple so they do
tease you a little bit with some of
their scenes together like wait you know
what's going on between the two of them
they have this weird chemistry together
so if you really enjoy that type of
stuff in previous seasons there's a lot
more of that this season but there is a
direct daredevil shout out during their
interactions that serves as a little
more crossover in a reference to the
daredevil Punisher relationship going
back to daredevil season 2 but for the
most part Punisher daredevil crossover
now is through the Karen Paige character
it's really like Karen Paige Punisher
crossover we cannot talk enough about
the action scenes as you would expect
they are a plus that's probably one of
the biggest reasons why you would watch
The Punisher TV show for the insane
stunts and crazy over-the-top battles in
gunplay he is the soul of fortuitous
violence in the Marvel Universe and
Punisher Season 2 holds nothing back you
even get a little bit of that from the
new john pilgrim villain character he
even ups the ante just a little bit more
in terms of how crazy they get with
their fight scenes but even though the
new John Pilgrim character has a couple
interesting moments he never quite rises
to the level of jigsaw in terms of
interest I mean he's supposed to be this
terrifying religious fanatic he's this
crazy mercenary and the religious stuff
gives him an interesting dimension but I
didn't quite feel like he was ever a
real threat to the Punisher and the
resolution to his character arc wasn't
all that satisfying so I wasn't really
excited with him by the end of the
season I was also not super hot on the
way they wrote the homeland security
agent Diana Madani that was returning
from season 1 her art had an interesting
conclusion but most of the season was
her spinning her wheels in a really
unsatisfying way if you felt like she
was the world's worst homeland security
agent during season 1 being completely
duped by jigsaw and not really figuring
out what was going on to the finale she
really doesn't get any better during
season 2 but the actress did a good job
with the material that they gave her I
feel like that was largely a consequence
of the way she was written not the way
that she was acted but if they do get a
season 3 then I feel like she'll be in a
much more interesting place in a much
more interesting character so like I
said sadly there
no micro that was a bit of a
disappointment they never really
explained where he or his family went
assuming that they're on the DL just
chilling out trying to lead a normal
life I think they left him out mostly in
service of pumping up the Punisher Amy
relationship which even though they had
a couple really good moments I was never
quite rooting for as hard as I was
rooting for Logan and Laura during their
movie but if you can get past some of
the taffy stretching in terms of story
pacing there are some amazing fight
scenes and a few really solid comic book
moments in what seems like a definitive
conclusion to all the story arcs they
set up in season one so if the show is
cancelled in a couple weeks you won't be
left with a bunch of cliff hangers
wondering what happens to all the
characters like what happens to X Y Z
like they answer all that at the end
everybody gets a definitive ending so
there aren't any really big questions
that I was left with in terms of the
characters this is mostly the story
season two a Punisher becoming
comic-book Punisher if you didn't feel
like that happened during season one
when I say that I'm talking about him
not wondering whether or not he's
actually going to continue as the
character like he's decided I am The
Punisher I'm gonna fully adopt this
persona and go about trying to clean up
the city the way that I do at best there
isn't any kind of post credit scene or
anything like that but what I might do
in a couple days is a video for the
ending and explain a little bit more
about what the producers and Jon
Bernthal have said about the future of
the show and how they feel about where
they left things right now as with all
Netflix shows they'll probably pitch a
third season if they haven't already but
that doesn't guarantee that Netflix is
gonna pick them up or anything like the
daredevil season 3 show runners like
Iona go pitch season 4 then a couple
weeks after that Netflix was like yeah
we're definitely canceling daredevil
there's gonna be no season 4 if it
really does turn out that they get
cancelled I'll say Jon Bernthal has been
the most fantastic Punisher that I've
ever seen I really do hope that whatever
Marvel decides to do with the character
next they keep Jon Bernthal on as the
character regardless of whether or not
they want to keep his TV show and
continuity or they just want to
completely reimagine him or put them in
the MCU and just already have him be the
Punisher and not deal with any of that
backstory we can talk more about that
when I do my next Marvel Netflix video
but leave all your requests in the
comments below and let me know what you
thought of the season in general once
you have a chance to see it or at least
a couple of the episodes here's my
new ranking of my top five favorite
Marvel seasons so far so it goes number
one daredevil season 1 still my favorite
daredevil season 3 because I felt like
that was a new high for the series
daredevil season 2 then Punisher season
2 in Jessica Jones season 1 let me know
in the comments what's your favorite
season of all the Marvel Netflix shows I
know a lot of people were questioning
whether or not they wanted to take the
time to invest in actually watching it
if it's just gonna be cancelled in a
couple weeks it's definitely worth
checking out for Jon Bernthal and those
crazy action scenes if there's nothing
else that you find really compelling in
it so definitely give it a chance if you
have it already but what will happen is
they'll be more Marvel stuff posting
this weekend leave all your requests in
the comments below click here to learn
about the really big surprise Marvel
characters that bought The Avengers
Tower in the spider-man far from home
trailer and click here to rewatch both
of those spider-man far from home
trailers thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight